la première phase d'aménagement du
boulevard de la République à Versailles
est lancée ce lundi 11 juillet plusieurs
ouvriers paysagistes ont abattu une
dizaine de tyleules malgré la présence
d'opposants au projet nous sommes
consternés et très en colère certains
sans doute étaient pas en très bon état
il fallait les abattre d'accord mais la
plupart étent encore très sain donc
c'est un une atteinte incroyable à notre
paysage urbain l'abattage des tyleuls
devait laisser place à une piste
cyclable des places de stationnement
payant pour sécuriser les trottoirs et
de nouveaux arbres sur tout le boulevard
de la République un projet contre lequel
un recours devant le tribunal
administratif a été déposé nous
demandons à la mairie de réfléchir et de
de d'entrer en concertation avec nous et
de ne pas réaliser ce projet dont
personne ne veut dans le quartier de
monreuil la concertation demandée par
l'association concerne la deuxème partie
du boulevard de la République à partir
des rues Montreuil et Alexis fouco
jusqu'au boulevard de la Renne il y a eu
quand même deux votes au municipal l'un
pour la piste cyclable et l'autre pour
le stationnement payant ce projet est
passé deux fois au conseil municipal le
le fondement du projet c'est de rendre
au piétons aux habitants du Bouvard la
République et au passagers piéton
l'usage des trottoirs un usage perdu à
cause des stationnements illégaux entre
les arbres en 2017 une concertation aura
lieu sur la dernière partie du projet
entre les différents acteurs